Всіх вітаю Отже сьогодні на засіданні
Верховна Рада України відмовилася
поставити в порядок денний Постанову
табеля якою блокується вирішення питання
щодо повернення виплат військовим власне
от поки ця постанова не проголосована в
залі закон не може бути підписаний Ані
головою Верховної Ради Ані президента
наша фракція намагалися внести цю
Постанову цабеля сесійну залу аби
депутати чесно визначилися але за було
лише 90 голосів бачимо що ну парламенту
уникає тут рішення І сьогодні ми
зустрічалися з керівництвом силового
блоку до погоджувальної Ради завітали
головнокомандувач Валерій залужний
представники Міністерства оборони
внутрішніх справ служби безпеки України
керівництво цих структур і ми домовилися
створити робочу групу на якій прийняти
от обговорити такий цілий блок
військових законів тому що ну очевидно
що бюджеті мало але повертати виплати
так само потрібно тому що якщо їх рік
тому ввели і виплачували рік треба
знімати ці кошти з інших колумбійських
статей бюджету і наша фракція До речі
тут пропонує де їх можна знайти
починаючи з цього дорожнього будівництва
яке сьогодні триває під час війни
закінчуючи Так званим марафоном ми всі
ми цими дамами іфрідами взагалі Якщо
говорити про сьогоднішній засідання
Верховної Ради України то прийнято 31
законопроект серед них є достатньо
важливі і в тому числі такі які
безпосередньо стосується допомоги
військовим ми створили буде створено в
Україні національне меморіальне
кладовище це законопроект мого
співавторство в тому числі місце обрано
дуже символічно на биківні там де
биківнянські могили де наші розстріляне
відродження і Путін який є неповним
таким пекельним продовженням Сталіна має
бути пока очевидно ми маємо притягти
його до відповідальності але наше тисячі
військових які вбиті були рашистами
мають бути гідно вшанована їх пам'ять і
тому буде створена це таке меморіальне
кладовище для наших військових
службовців для героїв Також ми підняли
питання що всі військові які загинули як
герої звичайно мають бути нагородження
державними відзнаками їх родини мають
отримувати всі виплати не взагалі
військових треба шанувати тому для нашої
політичної сили повернення 30 тисяч для
тих хто сьогодні в армії в Збройних
силах України хто захищає країну Це
питання принципове так само сьогодні
прийнято два важливих законопроекти в
цілому які стосуються
реабілітації військових і от роботи цих
військово-лікарських комісій які
сьогодні є справжнім знущанням над
пораненими тому що можна днями стояти
пораненим цих безкінечних чергах Там
дуже багато
змпотованими кінцівками все це абсолютно
приниження власне сьогодні прийнято
законопроекти щодо збільшення цих
військово-лікарських комісій можливості
створювати їх в різних закладах медичних
і можливостей обміну там документацією
такою для довідок в електронному вигляді
не щоб вони не їздили по всій країні не
перевозили оці документи паперові не
стояли в чергах це дуже важливо серед
законопроектів які стосуються
військового блоку також прийнято
важливий законопроект про застрокову
можливість
присвоєння військових звань для тих
військовослужбовців які
своєю професійністю відвагою довели що
вони готові до цього службового
підвищення очевидно що в умовах війни не
треба чекати для цього роками ну і
серед законопроектів які прийняті її
важливими це постанова Верховної Ради
про визнання путінського режиму
рашиським очевидно
що це абсолютно нацистська сьогодні
ідеологія люди ненависницька яка
здійснює сьогодні ця держава геноцид в
Україні проти українців і тому ми маємо
про це дуже відверто не тільки говорити
і фіксувати і вважаємо що всі ці рішення
вони лягають в основу майбутнього
трибуналу над режимом Путіна який
обов'язково має відбутися ну власне На
жаль парламент поки що залишається
закритим для журналістів ми бачимо так
лужі преси сьогодні порожні
після прийняття закону про медіа
Верховну Раду транслюють в запису раз на
місяць але цей блок пускають десь там
пізно пізно вночі Ну а цензура політична
На жаль залишається знаємо що депутатів
європейської Солідарності в цьому
Марафоні немає тому підписуйтеся на наш
YouTube канал на мій YouTube канал на
youtube-канали і соцмережами колег для
того щоб знати більше Правди все буде
Україна і Ми завжди будемо захищати
інтереси права наших військовослужбовців
Слава Україні